there are only two things that end up in
a briefcase like this nuclear codes and
stacks of money I know
just pretend Larry Summers has proposed
that we get rid of high denomination
currency like the hundred dollar bill to
make it harder for criminals to do
illegal cash hand offs so what would
this look like assuming we're criminals
with the little self-respect and we want
to stack our hundreds neatly we can fit
about ten thousand bills in this
briefcase which comes out to a nice even
million dollars between the case and the
cash this way is about 28 pounds but now
let's say Larry Summers gets his way and
we only have 50 s that million now
doubles in size we need to go back to
the store and get another briefcase then
get ready to haul almost sixty pounds to
our hand off then four 20s it's more
briefcases now we've got one hundred and
fifty pounds of money and so forth and
so on you get the idea in theory this
actually does seem like a cheap simple
solution to deter some crime
unfortunately one of the easiest ways
around this is just to use foreign
currency the Swiss of a note that's
basically the equivalent of a thousand
dollar bill so suddenly this stack turns
into this until we get the entire
international community on board the
reality is cash hand offs look a little
less like they do in Hollywood and a
little more like this